hi good afternoon dr. Wallach how are
you fine thank you how can we help you
today yes I was calling because I'm I
spoke with you before about the fibroids
and I'm taking the magician of
supplements for it but I was wondering
if I should increase it
okay well how much you weigh I'm gaining
weight like now wait - 6-2 6-0 yes and
how tall are you
five eight and a half okay five eight
and a half for a lady I'd like to see
you a 150 160 so you might want to lose
a hundred pounds here and so first of
all I need you on the the keto caramel
diet you need to take two meals a day it
could be any two of the three meals the
keto caramel shake or the Kino caramel
bar are you you know him breakfast for
the keel caramel shake and throw a
couple of eggs in there and then a
dinnertime have a bar that's it and then
of course for lunch you could have
steamed vegetables with a ice cream
scoop full of boiled or broiled fish or
ice cream scoop full of roasted meat or
a ice cream scoop full of roasted
chicken breasts and again you gotta get
rid of all the bad food Charmaine you
there Charmaine
yes I'm here I'm here we're talking
about other diet what do we need to get
Stephanie to give up here to get rid of
all the inflammation fried foods no
fried foods okay what else know me what
nitrates or nitrites in it and no rot
oils no oils exactly oils cause of
information yeah no no olive oil coconut
oil margins managed soldiers cooking
oils and what would you add to help
reduce inflammation and also to increase
efficiency of absorption get rid of what
well
well one thing she can do is take the no
gluten-free gluten-free gluten-free yeah
that's okay now that's going
lose some weight and so 260 pounds what
would you give her as a basic
nutritional program remember our goal
here is to give her what she needs to
help her body defend itself against
these fibroids in her uterus what would
you give her 260 pounds ideally uh but
she really needs three I'd give her
three healthy brain and her pecks
personally for issues she has exactly
and and and I give her the woman's
effects in this era from okay three
three quarks to the woman's effects as
you can take three ounces a day on some
breakfast lunch and dinner three bottles
a month of the 0fm x craf p.m. so you
could take two or three of those tablets
three times a day and then how much Rev
would you give her she needs to lose a
hundred pounds or so what would you get
oh she probably should get two bottles
of that yeah two bottles of Rev I go
along you get an A plus there dear and
so Stephanie you need to get two bottles
of Rev or evey and take two droppers
full before each meal but a dropper full
under your tongue thirty minutes for
each meal for the second dropper full
under your tongue fifteen minutes for
each meal let absorb their old tissues
and after a couple of days you should
literally begin to lose a half pound of
two pounds a day and because you're
avoiding all the inflammation which is
really the basic root cause of fibroids
and your giving support to the uterus
through the woman's FX and as their FM
your your body wants to heal itself it
just needs the raw materials to do that
and this goes by body weight you could
be doing all the right stuff and not
changing your diet and and under dosing
and not get any result and so you have
to do the right dose you have to avoid
all the bad stuff so you can maximize
absorption and eliminate the ongoing
damage so you have to do both